في الولايات المتحده المشهد السياسي يزداد
تعقيدا لدى الجمهوريين بعد نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه التي كانت مخيبه
للامال مع اقتراب اعلان ترامب ترشحه رسميا
للانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه والتي فتحت
طبعا باب التساؤل حول مستقبل الرئيس
السابق ترامب ومواقف اعضاء حزبه المتضاربه
من تواجدها على الساحه السياسيه ومدى
قدرتها على لاعب ادوار مستقبليه مهمه
فترام الذي لا يزال يحتفظ بشعبيه لا يمكن
انكارها يستعد للاعلان عن ترشحه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه للعام
2024 رافضا دعوات من بعض الجمهوريين
بالتراجع وهنا تتزايد المخاوف من دخول
الحزب الجمهوري في دوامه الفوضى الداخليه
خصوصا ان ترامب يسع هذه المره لتحطيم فرص
منافسيها المحتملين بمن فيهم ديسانتس وانا
ابيه السابق فمع اقتراب موعد الترويج لخوض
الانتخابات اسيه يبدو ان قبضه ترامب
الحديديه على الحزب الجمهوري تتصدع فبعض
الجمهوريين بعض منهم لم يعودوا متاكدين
حتى مع ان مع ترامب انه قادر على القياده
وفقه ما كشفه متابعون لصحيفه بوليتكو
[موسيقى]
ساقوم باعلان كبير يوم الثلاثاء 15 من شهر
نوفمبر
وساقول باقوى طريقه ان الانتخابات المقبله
ستنقذ البلاد
العديد من الجمهوريين يرون ان ترامب تسبب
بتشكيل عواق عوائق سياسيه وتصدعات داخل
الحزب بدعمه لبعض المرشحين دون البعض
الاخر في انتخابات التجديد النصفي الاخيره
ووفقه صحيفه بوليتيكو ايضا فكي كبار
الجمهوريين دعوا اترام لتاجيل اعلانه
للترشح الى ما بعد جوله الاعاده في مجلس
الشيوخ في جورجيا الشهر المقبل وفق
مراقبين للتطورات الحاصله فان اشد حلفاء
ترامب المخلصين رفضوا تقديم الدعم له ففي
مجلس النواب حيث ترامب بتاييد اكبر كما
قال البعض انهم سيراقبون عن كثب اطلاق
حمله ترامب المحتمله لكن القليل منهم
كانوا على استعداد للالتزام بتاييده
وقالوا بان الاولويه حاليا هي لاعاده
العمل من اجل السعاده اضراب الذي اختار
البقاء في الساحه السياسيه
ومواصله تسجيل المناصريه انتخابيه في مخت
انحاء البلاد يمكن ان يعيق طموحه للعوده
الى البيت الابيض عدد من التحقيقات في
سلوكه قبل ولايته الاولى كرئيس وخلالها
وبعدها مما قد يؤدي في نهايه المطاف الى
استبعاده ايضا وفق بعض الصحف الامريكيه
[موسيقى]